bienvenue dans ce nouveau paf avec un
sommaire complet puisque nous allons
parler des manifestations des jeunes de
la loi sur le travail des migrants
la situation des migrants des primaires
à droite et aussi du salon du livre avec
sa mini caussens jeux théâtre le prisme
on dit tu es autres noms comme si on
peut dire théâtre leur décision du de
prise tout seul on pense plutôt à une
figure géométrique ou alors on dit le
prisme le centre de développement
artistique de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est beaucoup plus on parle beaucoup
pris l'affairé très joli mais enfin
c'est moins vrai théâtre classique
jean-luc madec aurait on dit de la
commanderie des templiers 8 du resteront
en fait le développement de la
restauration au sein de la commande des
templiers du xiiie siècle
voilà c'est un peu plus long si rejet
paraît déjà au xiiie siècle noah notarié
plus tard le petit mot avec florence
mercadé du barreau de versailles qu'il
devait existait déjà ou peut-être un peu
plus tard ils ont ça me lajoie dit non
je éditeurs et justement je voulais
commencer avec vous ensemble puisque
vous revenez de ce padd du salon du
livre de la porte de versailles dont la
venue était la corée du sud
il ya beaucoup de choses intéressantes
dans ce salon comme tous les ans il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup moins d'éditeurs
aussi ce qui est un peu inquiétant c'est
très cher les stands sont assez hors de
prix donc c'est un peu compliqué et puis
là une sorte de bronca un peu du public
qui râlent parce que l'entrée est
payante mais bon si l'on traitait pas
payante les stands sera encore plus cher
pour les éditeurs pour bien que chacun
gagne ça me choque pas mais personne
n'aura le coton on paye pour le salon de
l'agriculture pour aller acheter un
sandwich à l'intérieur donc pas pourquoi
on aura le rêve de payer pour aller
acheter les livres face des pas ses 12
euros c'est pas non plus des
démentiellement non il ya dix il ya des
réductions sur des plus adroits même là
aujourd'hui c'était une journée dans le
scolaire
on est vendredi à voilà on a oui parler
sa démission l'europe voilà j'avais un
petit peu l'impression que de nuées de
great de grillons sur l'a6 on l'appelait
main parce que on sent tous ces enfants
qui arrivent qu'ils prennent ne marque
pas sur les stands les flyers ont été
posées c'est pas 6 h mais il ya là il ya
quand même une bonne valeur au-delà du
9e salon du livre évidemment quelques
années un peu le réceptacle mais c'est
que
contrairement à peut-être à ce qu'on
pouvait croire les français nous disent
de plus en plus on monte un peu mais ça
c'est énorme mais enfin ça c'est très
sympa parce que d'abord le mieux le
chiffre d'affaires de l'édition est
quasiment stable stable à la baisse
suivant quelle énorme truc assez grosse
les seniors sa fermeté pour ce moment
mais moi je dois d'abord quoi qu'on lise
c'est toujours bien de moi il suffit de
dire voilà avec soit des bd des livres
que certains peuvent trouver ni implique
d'autres vont trouver géniaux et ses
hommes et donc les français disent plus
les français sont très attachés au
papier parce qu'elle est à la rue
méritaient pas america's apprend pas
beaucoup voilà ça s'apprend pas assez
alors c'est c'est pour plusieurs raisons
il y en a une aussi c'est que
franchement une bonne liseuse c'est
quand même assez cher
ces deux ans 250 euros pour avoir un
truc correct et agréable à lire et c'est
facile de dents de manipulation donc 150
euros mais c'est quand même une certaine
somme toute ne peut pas l'acheter c'est
comme ce qui est merveilleux avec une
liseuse c'est que ça se met dans sa
poche mais comme tout truc qui suit dans
sa poche ça se perd aussi facilement
donc regarder si on perd un truc de 150
euros
c'est l'avis des chercheurs qui disait
que quand on lit sur quelque chose
d'électronique on ne retient absolument
pas ce qu'on lit parce que la lumière
vient de l'extérieur alors que
l'éclairage d'un livre en papier n'est
pas le même et qu'on voyait beaucoup
plus colis sera papier qu'est ce qu'on
lit sur un c'est un support alex 3 x ça
monsieur n'avait pas vu ça mais je veux
bien le contre mais que je lis
énormément de manuscrits d'amour et je
ne serai pas j'en reçois en papier et
j'en reçois en ordinateur enfin que tu
dis sur une bise
sur ma tablette etc et c'est vrai que
j'ai tendance à bien mieux me souvenir
des bouquins que j'ai vu en papier je me
dis ah oui tiens ça c'était bien mais
après je l'aimé
de quoi quel était le sujet que j'avais
un peu de balles les os x sur un livre
papier on va plus facilement en arrière
que sur une liseuse une liseuse on va
pas se retrouver les le post que tu te
poses oui oui il en faut mais vous êtes
liseuse ou oui je regardais jean-luc
lectrices normes électriques de liseuses
les deux noms n'ont ils pas jay de
papier non parce qu'en fait ce que je
pense aussi c'est que je suis d'accord
avec jean charest avec florence mais il
ya aussi que le fait que je tiens le
livre je peux rentrer dans un univers
plus facilement certainement bêtement
parce que c'est ma main droite et mame
ngor qui tient quelque chose et c'est
peut-être pour ça que je rentre par là
où je veux rentrer alors que sur une
tablette j'ai du mal je débite le texte
mais j'accroche - par certains endroits
mon attention s'en va plus facilement
parce que dans le livre je perds je
m'approprie jean-luc vous n'êtes plus
papier ou plus alors mon épouse et
liseuses et moi je suis papier lentement
je suis dans la saga de ken follett 3
moukam mille pages chacun écrit tout
petit c'est un peu alors en plus grande
tard je vais vous aurez un peu râlant
jeu ce qui fait que le livre m'endors
assez facilement oui vous avez raison
c'est parfait avec une liseuse faudra
mettre la police ont plus grand guichet
et doit pas avoir un look a eu mille
pages et dans les rixes date floral art
parce que tout ça c'est qu'il fallait
non pas grandie moi je suis plutôt je
suis plutôt papier et liseuses quand je
pars en voyage
oui bien sûr ma liseuse et je pars
rapport
et aux états unis ça prend assez comme
ça avait beaucoup fin très bien démarré
c'était entre 20 et 25% du marché et
puis depuis deux ans ça ça s'effondre un
peu d'abord ce qui s'est cassé la gueule
à ventes de liseuses aux états unis que
tout le monde en acheter mais là ça
s'est vraiment marqué un cap ça diminue
et puis les livres numériques diminue
aussi donc si en train de se
rééquilibrer à la baisse et du coup
c'est vrai que nous commençons suis
toujours un peu les états unis sur en
tout cas sur beaucoup de pratique avec
un peu de décalage un peu de retard
c'est vrai qu'en france aussi les ventes
de liseuses se sont un peu arrêter cette
année c'était très mauvais l'année
dernière ces concepts moins bon donc
latent qui tant qu'il n'y a pas de
liseuses très effet très bonne bien
meilleur marché je pense que sa soeur
décolère pas nous on parle là de mon cas
on fait on fait quoi 3 % de ce qu'on
fait en papier en numérique et la base
elles mêmes devraient uniquement congrès
dilma de contrairement à ce que tout le
monde pense tout le monde pense que le
livre numérique les éditeurs sont
maintenant les postes où ça coûte rien
mais ça coûte
dans un livre c'est pas de papiers qui
coûte cher il faut arrêter cette idée là
quoi c'est éventuellement les retours de
librairies ça c'est très cher mais ce
qui coûte hier dans un livre il ya les
hyènes l'auteur cécilia des retours sur
le cd électronique
il yal également des retours possibles
comme tout ce qui est acheté voilà je
parle sous le contrôle de l'experte
mais comme tout ce qui est acheté par un
sur internet bien une possibilité de
retour pendant huit jours donc
légalement quelqu'un peut le rendre rome
son livre sur un livre c'est région
seule machine à laver c'est peut-être
moins compliqué mais sur un livre on lit
lieu au moins deux jours et on leur en
parle mais en fait il y a
un système chez tous les distributeurs
de livres numériques qui fait que la
personne qui fait ça deux fois après
peut plus acheter de bouquins sinon ce
qu'on veut c'est là peut-être apple ya
une autre chose qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est de le livre l'impression à la
demande qui parait-il est un océan en
hausse et là ça se passe comment ça
c'est à dire qu'on demande à un éditeur
d' iliad où il ya deux choses il ya on a
beaucoup parlé
les puf les presses universitaires de
france qu'elle ouvrait une belle
boutique en plein coeur de paris où là
on peut venir et sur catalogue des donc
des pulls ff et de quelques autres
collections on demande le bouquin et en
dix minutes le temps de prendre un café
le bouquin est imprimé enfin un rôle y
est imprimé voilà au but deux minutes
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont dans leur
dans leur chute dans le géant lundi pour
en acheter dans leur programme top même
ancien des sas et d'idées c'est
justement posé des choses qu'il ne faut
pas ignorer
on n'a pas une idée à une demande des
monstres est évidemment parental si
c'était aussi pour faire mille
exemplaires un parent ça n'aurait pas
d'intérêt
donc c'est un client car et qui dit moi
tiens moi je voudrais ce bouquin la voix
les plus en stock
le client peut venir avec une clé usb en
disant j'ai un bouquin dans la clé usb
j'aimerais que vous de l'imprimé voilà
également aussi après c'est un truc qui
existe à la route là au delà des puces
pour tous les éditeurs pour justement
les livres un peu en fin de vie où il ya
plus de demande suffisante pour
réimprimer 500 ou 1000 exemplaires
quelqu'un d'une quantité minime aux
mines et a privé comme une photocopie
pas tout à fait à ce que ces de
l'impression numérique ont aimé
l'impression numérique a fait de tels
produits
progrès que maintenant c'était faut
vraiment être expert pour entre deux
bouquins ça c'est une machine classique
c'est du numérique mais ça reste de sa
reste du numérique donc avec peut-être
de temps un tout petit peu de
difficultés sur certaines couvertures
sur des vernis sur des sur des choses
sont pas tous n'est pas possible sur des
couvertures numérique 1 et les livres
qu'on trouve
après on va passer à autre chose mais
les livres qu'on trouve sur internet par
exemple notre jeu c'est pas besoin de
consulter un lit mais qu'ai je pense
dans le bonne public et je les trouvais
en entier sur internet sas à des niveaux
qui sont dans le domaine public c'est
bien là oui parce que je voyais à la bnf
la bibliothèque nationale de france qui
a un énorme fonds qui a été numérisé des
tonnes de livres est où là on peut
effectivement les avoirs de 2,7 et
graphiquement ça va être des on pourrait
aussi des erreurs petit puisqu'ils sont
libres de droits on pourrait enfin on
peut sûrement trouver une pièce de
molière gratuitement mais on peut aussi
la trouver payante chez un autre éditeur
qui a envie de l'éditer dit oui il ya
des notes et voilà tout
alors on va parler d'un poids politique
pour faire plaisir à sabine annoncé la
passion vous vivriez pas au sens
politique et l or donc je savais qu'elle
avait il y avait des élections
législatives partielles la semaine
dernière ont dès jeudi et vendredi donc
le deuxième tour n'a pas encore eu lieu
et il devrait le dimanche il ya un
suspense a pesé lourd à supporter pour
savoir qui va gagner je vous de voir un
reportage justement sur ce premier tour
des élections législatives partielles à
versailles seulement 12,98 % pour le
candidat socialiste multiplication des
listes à gauche et dynamique nationale
ont eu raison des ambitions de tristan
jacques dans la 2e circonscription des
yvelines
maire-adjoint de magny les hameaux où il
ne devance son adversaire de droite que
de 3%
il avait pourtant tenté de montrer ses
différences avec la politique du
gouvernement
insuffisant pour une candidature commune
avec europe ecologie les verts
l'une des seules formations en
progression par rapport à 2012 moi j'ai
continué à faire du port tous les jours
j'ai fait ma part déjà allé l'argent des
droits comme je n'ai peut-être pas la
garde de l'armée chantier voila je
contenais volonté de frapper aux plus
grands de par le ps a dit viser son
nombre de voix par quatre les
républicains par deux et finalement on
est les seuls en ondes en nombre
d'électeurs qui nous maintenons bien on
a à peine baissé
donc c'est une super nouvelle on donnera
pas de consigne de vote puisque les
électeurs sont libres de leur choix ça
s'appelle la démocratie et c'est très
bien comme ça
sauf surprise c'est donc pascal thévenot
maire de vélizy soutenu par les
électeurs de sa commune qui devrait
l'emporter sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription il totalise plus de 46%
ma campagne s'arrête pas quel que soit
même si on peut imaginer que il ya de
grandes chances que j'arrive à
l'emporter dimanche prochain mais c'est
ma nature et puis j'ai été à bonne école
avec valérie pécresse là dessus une
élection ça se gagne que le soir à 20
heures
donc là je serai encore sur les marchés
je serais encore en porte à porte
je rends encore des équipes dans toutes
les gares et gens nagent les acomptes
brière à tous les matins un duel droite
gauche pour le second tour programmé
dimanche qui masque le résultat du front
national quatrième devancé par benjamin
lacombe issu du mouvement yvelines pour
tous la liste manif pour tous en réalité
est un copier coller de notre programme
ils sont également contre contre
l'immigration massive ils sont pour la
sortie de schengen ils sont pour pour le
débat sur l'euro on voit que nos idées
sont très présentes maintenant leur
présence à eux a permis justement au ps
de se maintenir et de rester au second
tour de cette élection on retiendra
surtout la faible participation à peine
30 % des électeurs se sont rendus aux
urnes
c'était donc l'ancienne circonscription
je ne peux pas dit de valérie pécresse
qui est devenue présidente de région
donc circonscription qui était qui
t'avait droite mais cobham
il y à il ya un effondrement même si les
filles au deuxième tour et même si le
résultat du 2e tour n'est pas encore
acquis
du candidat du ps n'ont fait hélas rien
d'autre à 10 1% et il monte de de cette
discipline pour tout ce qui est en effet
issu de deux des manifestations contre
le mariage pour tous qui devance le
front national voilà mieux rire de rien
de spécial à dire sur ces élections on
verra après le deuxième tour les
résultats complets puisque c'est vrai
que c'est le deuxième tour ici c'est
souvent plus instructif quand je n'en
vois vraiment avec une faiblesse surtout
de l'apparition et la participation
s'est rétabli enfin bon honnêtement on
comprend que ça va passer un peu joué
d'avancé mais pas en vouloir aux gens de
parler voter c'est possible mais c'est
la représentation du peuple centre
présentent une obésité
oui ces inscriptions ou les gens
beaucoup de gens pouvaient penser que
c'était un peu joué d'avancé
alors autres faits politiques qui
concerne le territoire c'est
l'annulation de l'élection du président
de la communauté d'agglomération on
regardera ce sujet puis on comprend tout
de suite après on est satisfait parce
que parce que c'est aussi au delà de la
décision ça montre que il est nécessaire
vraiment que tout le monde se remette
autour de la table et qu'on arrête de
manière très claire des méthodes de
travail
nous ça fait des mois qu'on demande à ce
qui est une charte de bonne gouvernance
pour savoir où on va dont par où on va
et comment
et ça nécessite de réfléchir ensemble et
c'était pas vraiment l'ambiance jusqu'à
présent donc on espère que ce jugement
va ramener chacun à la raison alors
c'était le bonheur de sandrine grands
groupes représentant du parti socialiste
ayez une annulation c'est pour une
question de forme
oui c'est une question de forme
clairement les élections municipales de
mars 2014 était nette de la droite vise
à y a pas de changement de la loi voilà
doit remporter la gouvernance de la vie
de nouvelles là pour une question de
forme on annule tout phr commencer
il y avait des décisions très lourdes
qui ont été prises en amont là
maintenant ça va bloquer des décisions
pour encore une période très sincèrement
on parlait à l'instant de l'abstention
est ce que c'est parce que les gens
pensent que c'était gagné d'avancé
puisque c'est parce qu'ils se
désintéressent de cette forme politique
je pense que c'est le deuxième cas les
gens commencent à se désintéresser
voyez vous ils vont ils vont voter qu'on
respecte leur vote c'est la moindre les
zorra démocratie or là pour des primes
de forme et c'est pas la preuve que ça
arrive pas seulement dans la ville
nouvelle mais aussi en france on voit
que on se chicane sur des choses
absolument sans importance pour en tout
cas
les citoyens qui eux demandent aux
politiques d'avoir une vision pour leur
avenir et ceux de leurs enfants
quelle vision at on l'a on a eu le
toupet hommes de forme alors qu'on sait
très bien que la droite est au pouvoir
dans la ville nouvelle de saint quentin
en yvelines pour un con il ya des
actions à entreprendre
il ya des initiatives à prendre qu on
laisse les gens pour qu'ils nous avons
voté prendre ces initiatives après il ya
un respect de droits bien sûr il ya le
respect du droit d'accord enfin écoutez
vous avez regardé comme moi ce qu'il en
était à l'égard de la tacc pour lequel
le tribunal administratif a décidé
d'annuler question c'est vraiment sans
grande importance
eu égard encore une fois aux enjeux est
ce que vos dispose à bloc un peu voilà
bien fusion et c'est bon la ville
nouvelle
elle est vivante il ya des entreprises
qui arrivent d'autres qui pensent
certaines sont en difficulté il ya des
emplois créés et rang de transport de
logement qu'on agisse bon sens et qu'on
laisse les gens qui ont été élus pour ça
agir d'accord prêtre un point de vue
intéressant mais enfin ce qui ce qui est
plutôt positif c'est que ça n'a pas
bloqué les actions du président non mais
je sais ce que je veux dire c'est que
tant qu'il ya eu ce recours on n'a pas
eu un gel des actions de la part du
de michel laugier doit quand même
avancer sur un certain nombre de sujets
ce qui va faire faire des élections
rapidement si juste pas durer solinas
cassia soit là peut avoir six mois de
2011 va faire appel et kiki qui
prolongerait évidemment le délai soit
accepter cette adulation offert des
élections ce qui est peu difficile je
suis entraîneur conseil communautaire et
refaire lundi sûr mais quel spectacle
affligeant de nos électeurs
faut arrêter ça enfin moi je suis de
l'avis de l'ansés inquiet le droit c'est
le droit s'il ya une chose qui va pas
alors qu'ils font on peut trouver ça
anodin quand ça nous arrange pas exprès
mais il n'y a pas de limites il fut le
droit c'est le droit faut respecter la
loi et la règle ça s'est passé il va la
respecter
la jeunesse mais ça ne peut faire
autrement peut-être un mot quand même
deux de ses réformes notamment la
réforme du droit du travail de l comrie
puisqu'on a vu le premier ministre
partir bon debout disons je ne reculerai
pas j'irai jusqu'au bout sa nuit puis ça
a duré jusqu'à ce que voilà déjà deux
manifestent dans la rue un recul tout on
se réunir dimanche à l'elysée on réécrit
vite fait loi dit finalement ne
satisfait personne puisque la gauche
était déçu déjà la droite les deux si le
patronat se sent floué et finalement on
ne la loi une loi peut être entre les
boîtes qui sera peut-être efficace sur
cette façon de gouverner
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensaient des uns et
les autres c'est déprimant c'est
totalement déprimant cette reculade
permanente terre que ce soit les taxis
les souffleurs de de vtc de vpc les
jeunes qui sont extrêmement peu nombreux
à manifester
on se demande pourquoi on les écoute pas
si stupide maintenant d'être 12 dans la
rue pour faire ce jour et par des
anneaux mais on en a on a un peu
l'impression on a un peu l'impression
que le président a peur de tout
peut-être même de son nom est fière que
des quelqu'un à aimer un truc voilà on
va réfléchir il faut prendre en compte
mais je veux dire elle n'est pas élue
pour réfléchir et écouter la rue on
gouverne pas avec la rue face surtout
surtout avec une ruelle enfin solidaire
la ctc s'est rien passé c'est ridicule
c'est ces adolescents si les
journalistes eux mêmes leur boulot et
poser les vraies questions je serais
vraiment curieux de savoir ce que ce peu
de jeunes qui manifestent c'est vraiment
de la loi mais ils sont là oui on veut
pas de précarité ou comme garde à vue le
mineur quand même étudiant il ya 28 ans
il a une certaine expérience de la gifle
sur les lycéens problème majeur c'est
que visiblement représente une loi
par le gouvernement sans visiblement
avoir pris au préalable la précaution je
crois que ces saletés avec donc on fait
les choses à l'envers chute était
presque normale s'agissant d'un
gouvernement hongrois puisque bon à
l'époque je parle pour les équipes de
nicolas sarkozy on y allait vraiment
trop forte et région de nicolas sarkozy
de 2007 et des gens qui sont passés
absolument mes mails à la cera le taxi
et le saas est sauvé c'est pas à toi
donc là c'est pas la première fois qu'on
constate que on présente un projet de
loi sans en avoir discuté au près avec
des partenaires avec des partenaires
voilà mais simplement une tradition
ancrée quand on parle beaucoup puisque
les jeunes sont dans la rue dont on
compare beaucoup au cpe de 2002 villepin
mais c'était pareil c'était de deux
femmes qui avaient été préparés dans un
coin de bureau ou tout seul dans son
coin et consorts comme ça sans avoir
consulté via la moindre des choses pour
un gouvernement de gauche sont arrêtés
au moins se mettre d'accord avec la cfdt
en avoir au moins l'accord de sinthiou
d'ailleurs l'action mais déjà puisque
c'étaient les plus proches et les plus
faciles à cobham je vais jouer lens et
les permis pour une fois à la cgpme de
pouvoir prendre la parole ce qui est
assez relevé
il ya une anecdote assez amusant quand
le papier dans le jeu précédent le monde
sur les différents ministres du travail
et des anecdotes des uns et des autres
et il ya un type qui raconte les
discussions avec soissons à l'époque
ministre du travail qui était également
maire d'auxerre si mal et même s'ils
vendent et j'ai aussi pris quelques
syndicalistes arrive pour discuter dans
le bureau de soissons et bénévent ils se
tutoient et soissons les 10 c y regarder
un match de foot avec aux séries si
auxerre gagne se donne tout le sien pour
eux c'est vrai que ça pose la question
de pourquoi le gouvernement ne concerne
ne se concertera avec les indications de
réformes en france alors est ce parce qu
elle est parfois sociale normale mais si
on s'y prend bien pour l or mais qu
est-ce qui passaient pensais que ça
allait passer facilement parce que ça
gouvernement
on va dire tendance gauche prendraient
30 en guinée parce que c'est un peu
compliqué de dire de gauche comme ça
voilà ou alors parce que moi j'ai dû un
peu dans la presse qui à certains
journalistes qui ont fait un parallèle
avec matteo renzi en italie et au barça
les voilà où qui a fait passer carrément
sans rien demander à personne je veux
vraiment remercier manuel valls avait
pas suivi cet exemple la différence est
que matteo renzi des laves annoncé ces
réformes avant d'être avant d'être au
pouvoir
ah oui c'était ce n'est pas tout à fait
là quand même pas tout à fait là aussi
questionner mais c'est vrai que à chaque
fois aux dîmes la france et n'est pas
réformable
c'est grave mais quand même ici à néant
la méthode quand même mars
il faut surtout aller jusqu'au bout de
ses idées
sinon je ne vois pas pourquoi le
gouvernement reculer la sortie saint
gilles avec aller jusqu'au bout j'ai
tout laissé son prix des loyers lan
amateurs ils sont amateurisme incroyable
et je reviens encore une fois de plus
parce que ça avait été quand même assez
bien fait parce ou nicolas sarkozy
puisque les réformes importantes qui ont
été faites en 2007 2008 en droit du
travail pure avant de sortir le projet
de loi il a fait des réunions avec tous
les partenaires sociaux pour arriver sur
ce qu'on appelle là ni l'accord national
interprofessionnel où il ya eu des
accords nationaux interprofessionnels
qui ont été votées et ensuite donc signé
par les partenaires sociaux
et ensuite on est passé à la loi donc
qu'ils ont pris du temps pour essayer de
bâtir des choses avec les partenaires
sociaux et après on passe à la loi et il
n'y a pas eu problème parce qu'on est
passé sur cette méthode là alors là
c'est surprenant quoi je parle j'ai la
tête dans le sens sur une même s'il l'a
pas dit encore de gens est ce que ça
vient pas aussi de la mauvaise
représentativité des syndicats qui fait
que finalement se dit est-ce que ça vaut
le coup d'aller négocier avant de
revenir à présenter en sachant qu'elles
seront lier leurs positions mais dans la
présentation de la loire on voit bien
que on servait sow grosse boîte
la france c'est pas que les grosses
boîtes vous rappelle deux millions et
demi de petits patrons francs 60% des
salariés vous êtes sur les plafonnements
par exemple des ânes habilités de mal
mais attendue tant excusez moi qu'est ce
que vient faire là dedans
là le plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homale ça concerne quelques
dizaines d'entreprises par an mais c'est
rien du tout enfin soyons sérieux qui
permettra d excuser moi je connais un
seul le tribunal ne s'est pas résorbée
je vous assure que ça concerne
relativement peu de cas donc on en a
fait tout un travail là mais il y avait
des justes vient plus à ses parents non
mais là je parle je parle pas des procès
aux prud'hommes nombre d'amendés pas les
choses la plupart des procès nous sommes
d'abord sont gagnés par les salariés et
pas par les patrons ce sujet précis
c'est pour ça qu'ils aient un plafond
mais non mais écoutez lui de la faune
mans sur les 18 mois de salaire à 18 15
15 mois de salaire
franchement connaissons un peu comme ma
chère florence à vos cartes est
spécialisée dans ce domaine les
tribunaux de plus d'un peu d'entreprises
sont condamnés à quinze bleu ciel rue de
lappe 20 ans on a été très bien mais à
sa robe faisant peu de cas et voyez là
ça prend du temps c'est pensable
l'essentiel de la loi
cette rumeur c'est la musique les
annales la loi sadc d'assouplir le
symbole du grand défi s'énerver dessus
c'est terminé donc ça aussi ça jette
encore une fois dû des circuits pendant
cet intéressant que chef d'entreprise
nous disent attention les indemnités le
plafonnement de la timidité c'est pas un
vrai problème alors que ça a été un
homme crispation c'est un tort c'est un
tort c'est clairement à tort et c'est
clairement à tort de présenter en
permanence les lois et les réformes
unico pour les grandes entreprises pour
les défendre le bénéfice net à bâle ii
et des fruits
jean-luc le plafonnement pour les
grandes entreprises ce n'est pas un
sujet le sujet du plafonnement c'est
pour les tpe les pme pour avoir une
lisibilité cellules peuvent rien
demander en l'occurrence dans ce domaine
des tpe et les pme ont demandé un
assouplissement de manager ou non une
fois on les a bien entendu et l'édition
plafonnement de papa baba c'est un c'est
un sujet mineur comparé aux autres
sujets dans le cadre de la réforme du
code du travail je vous assure que c'est
le cas et je vous rappelle que les
bandes sont à votre disposition sur
internet
écoutez bien ce qu'a dit le président la
cgpme il n'a pas focalisé sur le
plafonnement des appareils que demain si
l'on a parlé de ce bus que c'était un
article avait pas grand chose à y
faire ce que nous demandons nous des
petites boîtes c'est simple c'est de la
souplesse d'une embauche des salariés et
et puis que l'on se fasse pas mener au
pilori dès lors que l'on doit prendre
une décision
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que dans les
grandes boîtes
d'abord on n'est pas représenté
malheureusement ou mal et on descend pas
dans la rue
et en plus on voit bien que ce qu'ils
descendent dans la rue c'est ça ne
représente en rien le tissu économique
français en rien là on parlait d'un
million de signatures un million de
signatures contre la loi elle conneries
quand vous voyez qu'il ya 7 millions de
personnes dans la fonction publique 2
millions d'étudiants
vous dites que un million de signatures
ça c'est facile mais ça retombe avec 44
millions de français qui sont censés
voter y en a 25 millions qui vont pas là
il ya un vrai problème
donc là encore une fois on est en train
de faire haro sur la politique et
évidemment les français n'ont pas voté
et les ports cause il problème de la
pétition c'est que la façon dont étaient
présentés dans la pétition la loi elle
conneries avec les questions étaient
donc la moitié de les questions étaient
fausses mais plus est elles sont
manipulées totalement bien sûr et on a
fait tout un travail sur le fait qu'ils
avaient et l'échangent vouloir aller ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est que c'était
sûr change.org et sur change pas en
qu'on a lancé une pétition pour la loi
elle conneries non prisonniers pas de
problème abu dhabi
enfin c'est encore un discrédit jeté sur
le monde politique dommages et beaucoup
de bruit quand même pour pas qu'on fait
rire
finalement les gens qui aujourd'hui
s'exprime sont-ils ce qui représente
vraiment les français
cet ingénieur et la clinique est là les
gens qui descendent dans la rue rameau
et très bien parlé de quelques centaines
d'étudiants d'un million de signatures
de pétitions qui veulent rien dire en
même temps les français que vous côtoyez
comme moi on en a c'est tout ça et
résultat des courses où il était il ya
qui reste plus à la politique et ils
attendent ils attendent quoi ils
attendent que ça bouge bien pardon il ya
peut-être autre chose alors au delà de
la loi elle même et est content
en effet ce que disait jean charest est
vrai je veux dire que beaucoup de gens
qui manifestent donc nous ne sommes pas
exactement ce qu'est ce qui est dit dans
la loi mais est-ce qu'il ya pas ce
sentiment quand même que les choses vont
être plus difficiles qu'elle n'était et
que les gens n'ont peut-être assez qu'on
leur demande de plus en plus d'efforts
de présenter les alienware si on
continue de marcher sur la tête oui ça
va être des finances mais je pense à
elle est visible dans mazuir pourquoi
pourquoi plus de précarité pour les pour
les salariés je dirais un moment il ya
peut-être une réaction 10 rebonds un peu
marre quoi mais je pense que sur ça oui
il ya eu une très mauvaise mais c'est ce
que vous disiez ce que disait jean
charles ya une très mauvaise explication
de sape et moi extrêmement mauvaise
pédagogie parce que si on la reprend
calmement sans hystérie en dehors
mettons exit les problèmes de
plafonnement et et de toute façon avec
mon expérience de 30 ans de droit du
travail je peux dire que les plafonds
qui ont été données ce qui correspond
aux condamnation prud'homale donc il ya
de quoi non il veut en faire un fonds
donc là il n'y a pas de quoi en faire un
fois la modification sur licenciements
pour motifs économiques tels que ça a
été revue en rétropédalage dernièrement
c'est la jurisprudence française
donc y'a pas de quoi non plus hurler
dire quoi que ce soit et cette loi en
réalité d'une espèce de synthèse de ce
qui existe en termes de jurisprudence
les sommes avancées
et c'est un peu la tune sur lequel les
gens n'ont pas trop réagi parce qu'on
entend parler les licenciements
économiques c'est scandaleux
le plafonne non c'est scandaleux c'est
tout ce qui va toucher aux 35 heures
puisque là il ya des possibilités et des
ouvertures extrêmement importantes sur
les 35 sur la stratégie
ça c'est aussi fini ça je veux retirer
nous retirer normale d'aidé sur la
séquence
si on les applique sans pression voilà
sur l'astra
ils ont retiré sur les apprentis
notamment sur sept qui peut faire plus
d'heures ils l'ont retirée également
mais ils ont laissé quand même les
ouvertures sur sur les 35 heures et sur
les heures supplémentaires sur la
négociation sur les sur la majoration
des heures supplémentaires sur le
quantum enfin il ya des tas de choses
qu'on peut continuer à faire entre eux
et ça ils n'ont pas de touché et est bon
donc la cfdt dit qu'aller maintenant
tout va bien elle va pouvoir avancer
dans ce sens là mais objectivement je
pense que en dehors de l'histoire des 35
heures il n'y avait pas de quoi en faire
une histoire c'est là qu'ils disent pas
surjouer blement difficile puisque là là
là on sait pas quel sera l'état des
députés de gauche que la droite vis
blanc qui donne un certain nombre de
gens auraient voté la première mouture
de la loi ne vont pas le faire peut-être
aussi divisés l'assemblée justement sur
le plan politique ce n'est pas si vous
avez la couverture de l'observateur où
on voit hollande et valls et le titre
c'est qui va tuer l'autre et il ya quand
même un peu de ça c'est dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'on va le dire et
jusqu'au bout il ya de ça trois semaines
un mois et puis que au fond il mange un
peu son chapeau est ce que il n'est pas
quand même un peu déconsidéré par part
justement là l'aptitude de la
négociation pour dire les choses comme
ça de françois hollande le seul but en
ce moment de françois hollande c'est pas
temps de s'occuper de la france que de
s'occuper détruire valse de saper le
moral n'en fallait pas beaucoup plus de
temps c'est pas démissionner dans ce cas
là le démissionner maintenant je pense
qu'ils préfèrent d'essayer de le
ridiculiser de deux finales
je pense que valls il avancé je pense
que valls il ya pensé très fort et
qu'après comme ces gamins type
extrêmement intelligent très combatif
etc
il a dû dire mais après tout pour dire
je peux faire une bouchée de macron une
bouchée de landais ira bien qui rira le
dernier
je pense que c'est ça mais c'est une
lutte j'imagine que quand ils sont tous
les deux ça doit être assez glacial
comme penser que le régime appelle
justement ça peut ça peut ne pas durer
jusqu'à 2017 à ta place
même si oui si jamais une vexation
la vexation de trop on pourra faire
disjoncter valls qui partira en claquant
la porte
dès lors la voie alors est-ce que le
calcul de vals et pas de se dire
probablement collant n'ira pas et que je
serai le mieux placé si je reste en
place pour être le candidat de l'eau ne
s'affaiblissent affaiblir le vide je
fais pas là non on ne peut pas dire
qu'il ya peut-être une résistance que je
comprenais 4s pour l'instant hollande ne
pense qu'à une seule chose c'est sa
réélection avec kylie plombe les choses
ça soit que ça soit possible voire est
vraiment sur quel sur quel avec quelles
alliances c'est toutes ces questions qui
se posent aux fruits oui enfin on a en
tout cas le spectacle qu'on donne en ce
moment ai-je vraiment pas brillant à la
jarrie que je me souviens que quand on
avait demandé quels étaient vos
personnages préférés de l'année n'avait
qu'un mot c'était françois le pape
l'église est ce qu elle apparaît par la
question depuis longtemps on va pas les
questions de pédophilie et en
particulier monseigneur barbarin
archevêque de lyon qu'on a que ne pas
avoir déplacé des des prêtres qui était
qui et qui auraient été des coupables de
faits de pédophilie
c'est un grave scandale pour l'église
dove scandale pour voir marin cela pour
la société c'est pour la société pour
l'église bien sûr mais pour toute la
société c'est un véritable souci dans le
sens où quand même nous sommes dans une
société qui est de d'obédience
chrétienne catholique
donc évidemment s'est inscrite dans nos
gènes dans notre culture est bon les
affaires de pédophilie pour les prêtres
sont pas d'hier
un certain nombre d'humoristes on en
fait même des sketches à l'acide
oui autant de chansons à la sinne
d'ailleurs bon donc là maintenant c'est
haro sur ce pauvre cardinal barbarin
haut
oui je pouffe cardinal barbarin des
prêtres pédophiles mais hélas il y en a
mais enfin il ya des pédophiles dans
toute la société
il est l'enfant bon je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé entre le moment où le type
était découvert et le moment où barbara
peut-être pas dit ce qu'il fallait dire
au bon moment mais enfin écoutez
franchement ça fait d'abord du mal à la
société française ça c'est clair
à l'église évidemment mais l'église fait
partie intégrante de la société dans
notre pays il ya vraiment des scandales
dans d'autres religions dont on ne parle
pas hélas le fait de focaliser sur les
catholiques à mon avis n'est pas une
bonne chose il faudrait peut-être lever
un peu le pied après le que la justice
fasse son travail et la fasse le mieux
possible en toute transparence ça c'est
un bien pour tous mais monnet dieu merci
gagnerait barbara scaff c'est ce qui est
effectivement tout un tout à fait
choquant à dire qu'il ya des religions
qu'on a bien évidemment pas le droit de
stigmatiser on nous l'a suffisamment dit
mais là en revanche la religion
catholique c'est la stigmatisation à
outrance dire qu'on peut stigmatiser les
couizanais juste à tous et qu'on peut
stigmatiser on a l'impression à lire
certains journaux ou à regarder
certaines chaînes de télévision que tous
les catholiques sont pédophiles que tous
les cas que tous les catholiques mais
que tous les cas ça on savait que tous
les catholiques mais je veux dire que
dix ans si c'est un déferlement de haine
contre tous les catholiques en ce moment
et là il ce n'est pas entendu une seule
voix pour dire a pas de stigmatisation
là on peut on stigmatise tous les jours
24 heures sur 24 les catholiques je
trouve ça un peu curieux que personne ne
dise attendait d égaler y mollo la
présomption d'innocence tout le monde
là-bas foot où on s'en fout
le barbarens et c'est une sims ne suis
pas au courant je ne connais pas le
dossier à fond mais je permettrai pas de
juger mais je trouve quand même curieux
ccpz déchaînement médiatique mais
démentiel dément c'est à dire que je
pense que ça rejoint des affaires qui
ont été peu ou pas résolu parce que je
crois que les prêtres dont il s'agit qui
sont donc pervers pédophile et qui ont
usé
enfin qui ont mis en exécution lors leur
perversité et donc il ya des jeunes qui
eux ont été en souffrance et le sont
encore des adultes qui le sont
aujourd'hui
je pense que cela ils ont été jugés et
je pense et ce qui est reproché au
cardinal barbarin c'est de ne pas avoir
pris de position au moment pour les
évacuer ou les mettre à les évincer
millet la juge lui il faudrait juste que
ça a été rendue sur ces cas là la
semaine c'est important quand même de
remettre juste d apprendre cette
histoire rejoint sa défense est de dire
que il là il l'a fait dès qu'ils
assument dallas est ce parce que le lot
pourquoi il ya une telle stigmatisation
je rejoins un peu le point de vue mais
bon je voudrais être un peu plus douce
là dessus je pense que ça rejoint des
cas où il n'y a pas eu de prise de
position il n'y a pas eu d' et donc ça
s'accumule ça s'accumule on l'a dit on à
l'éducation nationale qui est dans le
même cas
il faut quand même le dire important
pour marseille à lui à l'argile gens
sont baptisés catholiques ou pas je suis
d'accord les traditions judéo chrétienne
je dirais même judéo chrétienne pour
être plus vrai donc c'est très ancrée
voilà par contre moi je voulais juste
attirer l'attention sur le fait que les
décisions ne sont pas prises que les
choix ne sont pas fait d'éloigner ces
malades
ce sont des pervers sont pas des gens
c'est pas tous les prêtres c'est pas
tous les enseignants c'est pas tous les
hommes avec des petits garçons
voilà c'est quand même des pervers c'est
donc une maladie hockey à un moment
donné où le repérage n'est pas fait
l'accompagnement n'est peut-être pas
fait don qui sera peut-être se poser les
bonnes questions au bon endroit
puis de l'autre côté il ya la victime
est là la victime elle danse il s'agit
de religion vous disiez jean-luc on
était à prendre ça je me souviens très
bien moi quand j'étais gamine et qu'il
fallait que je me confesse j'inventais
dépêchés eux
franchement j'avais déjà quitté la
maison feature j'ai peur j'avais dit un
gros mot femme en bref parce que je
l'aimé vraiment et qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire voilà j'étais quand même une bonne
chrétienne finalement il n'avait pas
tant que ça habib l'antiquité
sauf qu'un gamin quand ils écoutent que
ses parents l'élève dans la religion que
le prêtre est une personne importante
qui représente quelque chose qui intègre
quelque chose l'enfant lui ne pas
prendre de distance puisqu'il est
cautionnée par les parents ce qui est
logique il va dans ce sens là et il sait
pertinemment qu'il a fait un pêché et y
voit un prêtre qui ne doit pas en faire
qui en fait un donc déjà se faire violer
c'est déjà pas terrible pour la
personnalité bien en plus dans un cadre
comme celui là c'est quasiment double
peine pour la victime tout leflux
d'ailleurs c'est pour moi
il est dit c'est claude amos qui le
disait surtout lâché l'attaquant donc
j'ai repris ses paroles parce que je
savais que le sujet on devait en
débattre parce que je trouve que c'est
quand même très dur donc je te voilà je
trouve que l'éducation nationale d'un
côté la rue yonge on n'arrête pas de se
battre il ya tout ça il ya des tas de
cas qui sont cités le problème de la
victime lui il est réel et dans le cas
de la religion je trouve que la double
peine parce que c'est un énorme péché
donc un petit gamin que dans un club de
scouts même s'il a 38 ans après il a
quand même énormément de mal à se
débattre avec tout ça voilà toutes été
respectées
on est d'accord ça pendant le haro sur
barbarin était passé derrière on parlait
de du pape françois je pense qu'on peut
garder profonde admiration pour cet
homme idéal sur les bras d'eau très
lourde responsabilité et un milliard
d'âmes a élevé pendant une partie devait
comme benoît 16 a siégé benoît sevenier
schiavetti rynshu on avait maintenant à
déposer au zéro tolérance zéro c'est ce
qui a fait qu'elle fait quand même
beaucoup de ménages donc je pense que
tout ça ça ressort coincé comme human
ibéro nous interroger parce que on a
entendu cet argument dont justement dans
la défense de l'élite qui est peut-être
un peu de mal à passer qui est aussi la
différence d'époque
c'est à dire que moi quand j'étais gamin
des prêtres qui avaient du mal à deux on
ne connaît tous
je vais passer du mois mais bon non mais
on en entendait parler je n'ai pas là et
il ya aussi pardon une condamnation
totale de la pédophilie je dis je ne
défends pas absolument pas la pédophilie
qui est devenu un tabou complet qui
n'existait pas il ya 20 30 ou 40 ans
l'enfant n'avait pas le droit de parler
non ce n'était pas les leurs fonds de
parler par l'enjeu lors qu'on ne parlait
pas qu'une reconnaissance de la parole
du tout donc on a la haute savoie là il
y avait des abus ou dd deschamps offert
à voilà peut-être c'est vraiment une
époque où l'adulte avait raison et
l'enfant avaient tort
tristement la société était pas du tout
alertés se sucent non je ne suis pas
comme aujourd'hui les chansonniers à
travers les humoristes à travers les
chanteurs il y avait de sacrés dégâts
veilleux alors c'est une façon de
montrer que ça existait mais venir
là je parle pas de l'église mais dans
l'après 68 et aux honneurs prochaine
cohn bendit
voilà il ya aussi l'idée de la
libération sexuelle ou disait il faut
apprendre la sexualité aux enfants donc
il n'y avait pas du tout le même rapport
de sexualité des enfants qu'il ya
aujourd'hui avec ducati
parce que je pense qu'il ya l'avant et
un à un avant et un après faire affaire
du tout mais qu'on peut dater à peu près
ça de l'armée mais c'est vrai que
c'était pas les mêmes choses puis à
l'époque c'est pareil faire en matière
d'inceste janvier veiller sur les
problèmes d'un cesse dans les familles
on mettait sa suite à pied j'ai vu tout
ça parce que c'est là c'est la même
chose c'était on pouvait pas parler
non mais moi j'avais fait des recherches
sur la criminalité au 19e siècle et vous
avez des départements comme la creuse où
il y avait aucun cas d'inceste d'abord
qu'ils ont joué dans les statistiques de
la grc c'est de faire en sorte que les
juges ne se transforme pas en doute
c'est sûr mais oui c'est vrai de savoir
quelle est très exactement quelle est
qu'elle est la sensibilité des uns et
des autres est-ce que vous avez pas été
alors je pense que vous l'avez été
puisque vous avez cette position est
alerté en tout cas quand j'ai entendu le
premier ministre dire aux propos du du
de l'archevêque de l'union qu'il devait
s'expliquer est ce que c'est le rôle du
premier ministre d'intervenir comme ça
dans la sphère réseau dont je ne sais
pas si connaît vraiment le dossier ou
pas enfin je pense qu'il devrait dire la
justice doit travailler points voulait
il prend des positions sur des
footballeurs
sur les cardinaux ricochet sur les
footballeurs parce que j'imagine qu'on
allait en parler après c'est un peu
différent parce que j'imagine que si
s'est exprimé sur benzema c'est qu'il
était au courant de la sortie hier ou ce
matin dans libé je pense que la ville de
saray manuel valls voit là et que donc
c'est deuxième histoire il est là
entendent y attend l'équipe de france
déjà pas terrible alors si en plus elle
a offert aux enfants de mme obama serait
mêlé à une affaire de blanchiment
d'argent qu'en tout cas en tout cas il
n'est pas un euro mon parti il a été
interrogé interroge eric connais des
gens qui ont blanchi des blogueurs
blanchi de l'argent de l'argent kg de
drogue mais traître mais mais mais mais
sachant sachant même ça est-ce que cet
os que c'était après midi de dire il
faut sélectionner un tifo l'équipe de
france c'est un moment
est-ce que vous parliez de la crise de
gouvernance on attend quand même d'aider
real on est quand même tombé très bas
oui quand même la proposition n'est pas
si vous avez habitués dernière
génération parce que visiblement ça
continue on n y sont pas dans la même
alors y'a rien ça il ya le fait qu y
at-il eu des chaînes d'info en continu
il faut qu' il ya toujours des débats
ces mots qu'il faut réagir immédiatement
sur l'événement qui arrivent et qui fait
que en effet alors peut-être que ça joue
aussi dans là dedans la dépréciation de
la fonction politique c'est
effectivement un peu choquant mais en
même temps on sait très bien que la
marge de manoeuvre de nos gouvernants
est assez limité alors au moins de temps
en temps j'ai peur je pense que pour un
premier ministre le texte est agréable
de se dire tiens là je vais pouvoir dire
quelque chose personne ne va troupe
contredire
je peux me lancer je peux avoir l'air
décidé un truc c'est un sujet voilà
c'est une petite fenêtre de tir
voilà je j'y vais je critique benzema et
et j'y vais les gens adorent le foot
j'ai une parole là dessus on aimerait
qu'il nous dise j'ai fait 2 millions de
chômeurs en moins mais non pays que par
ilfc comme il veut pas il parle de foot
ils sont là où on les attend pas j'ai
pas si vous avez eu son d'ajustement qui
explique que 90 % des français estiment
que le système démocratique fonctionne
plutôt balle en france plus de 12 points
par rapport à l'année dernière
93 % que les hommes et les femmes
politiques agissent principalement pour
leurs intérêts personnels
jusqu'à présent pour penser que les
femmes politiques étaient un peu mieux
considérées elles sont dans le même sac
et 77 % considèrent que la plupart des
hommes des femmes politiques sondés sont
corrompus c'est un petit sexe ici mais
je sais c'est qu'ils ont des patronymes
de 17% de son complice 67% des français
pensent qu'il se faisait dire qu'ils ont
une image quand même regarder le
spectacle on leur donne tant au plan
local qu'au plan national ou même au
point pour plan européen la sphère des
migrants mais est un exemple de
l'incurie de nos gouvernants à l'échelle
européenne comme je suis pas d'accord
parce que c'est trop facile d'abord sur
problème des migrants que faire qu'en
fait on va parler salaires des footeux
abraham migrants sont volés ou et on va
revenir mais les hommes et les femmes
politiques sont bien évidemment pas tous
des pourris ils passent leur temps
national sortant sur le terreau mais ils
sont d effort absolument incroyable ce
soit au niveau municipal local régional
à l'assemblée nationale à l'assemblée
là il faut pas prendre le sondage au
pied de la lettre mais il ya quand même
une déconsidération comme un terrible de
la culture basque oui parce que je pense
que c'est facile dans l'esprit du
français moyen et spéciaux et si souvent
médiocre vous du retour etc
mais c'est peut-être aussi une
projection de ddd des gens qui pensent à
qui dit pas oui c'est des corrompus ce
que moi à leur place je serais le
premier de ces corrompus c'est peut-être
ça le l'enseignement du truc ce qui est
quand même assez étonnant est
intéressant c'est que malgré ce jugement
très négatif
on a quand même de plus en plus de
candidats qui est enfin voilà il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas une crise des vocations
en tout cas on vous dit quand vous voyez
le nombre de candidats aux primaires de
la droite
moi si vous connaissez mon avis je
trouve que les primaires c'est le tout
le plus débile qu'on ait inventé et
c'est la pire des conneries qu'on est
importée des etats-unis alors je vais
pas changer d'avis tous à ce truc
ridicule c'est la mort des partis
politiques
on trouvera encore plus de faim c'est ça
ne veut plus rien ça sert plus à rien de
militer dans un parti maintenant puisque
toute la suite c'est évidemment la
qualité partie non mais donc ça veut
dire qu'il n'y aura plus n'y aura plus
de militants donc il y aura plus de gens
qui sont vraiment intéressés parce que
on peut critiquer encore une fois parce
qu'on critique toujours tout mais le
militant du ps comme le militant du
parti des républicains sont des gens qui
passent leurs soirées dans des dans des
meetings politiques dans des réunions de
section ou d'aider des réunions de
supporters de cohabiter pour 10 pour
discuter pour pour l'imaginer des
lendemains meilleurs pour trouver d'aidé
décidé et c'est plutôt que de regarder
la télévision avachi donne dans le calme
donc ces gens là beauté mais là
maintenant leur dis bonne façon ok vous
avez passé votre vie à réfléchir mais on
s'en fout on vous ouvrira la décision de
vous du candidat qui va représenter vos
idées à tout le monde n'importe qui pour
aller voter
vous avez milité ça n'a aucune
importance rentrez chez vous inscrire il
ya une énorme bêtise fait parler les
socialistes d'inventer cette primaire on
voit ce que ça a donné ce qu'on peut pas
dire que l'on était le meilleur candidat
quand même et non seulement c'est donc
un échec toi c'est un très bon candidat
non mais le résultat c'est vraiment très
bien c'est donc un truc était montée
toute pièce par le ps qui est un échec
absolu on voit on voit le mandat du
hollands et là tout le monde d'immeubles
investir moi c'est une bonne idée et
tiens bon tiens on va faire ça c'est sa
troisième but a dit si je fais 5 % des
élections aussi l'expression de
démocratie sur le sondage est et ce
qu'il est on aime ou on n'aime pas mais
c'est un sondage as un peu son âge
dans la circonscription de valérie
pécresse 70% des gens inscrits ne sont
pas ce ne sont pas les places et donc
c'est ça confiant le sondage ya quand
même un vrai dire que tous les français
sont des bleus on peut le faire mais bon
quelque part les français sont
normalement dès lors qu'ils sont
inscrits sur une liste électorale censée
aller voter qu'est ce qui dans
l'extraction la démocratie c'est ça je
vous coupe mais qu'est ce qui est
démocratique dans une primaire où un
type de gauche peut aller voter pour le
candidat de droite tous les candidats de
droite peuvent aller voter pour les
candidats de gauche c'est faux c'est
ainsi des résultats ça nice et c'est
tout sauf de la démocratie comment
probablement majoritaire de gauche je ne
pense pas que ce soit que des gens de
droite qui vont être surpris par des
spécialistes
on compte 80 bougent qu'ils vont faire
moi je connais plein de gens de gauche
le plein de gens de droite sont allés
voter aux primaires socialistes la
dernière fois et je connais plein de
gens de gauche que l'intention d'aller
voter aux primaires de droite ça se dit
bien évidemment majorité après tout pour
moi est un droit pas à plaindre
extrêmement complètement sa part vision
qui aimait faire de la politique et qui
n'en sont pas
sauf que jean lassalle va se présenter
et ça j'en parle pas un homme est-ce que
je peux juste revenir là-dessus ce que
tout à l'heure sur le sondage là j'étais
assez d'accord jean-charles parlait des
militants tout à l'heure mais les gens
qui s'engagent dans la politique qui ne
sont pas forcément ceux qui montent très
haut mais ceux qui sont sur le local le
municipal jean luc le disait aussi sont
des gens qui sont engagés dans la vie la
politique moi je parle de mon secteur
qui est la culture s'il n'y avait pas de
politique engagé mais il n'y aurait pas
de politique culturelle puisque c'est
quand même la politique locale de
proximité régionale départementale parce
que l'état c'est encore autre chose sur
d'autres lignes qui finance mais c'est
pareil pour le social c'est pareil pour
beaucoup de choses on peut le décliner
secteur économique on est d'accord mais
c'est bien l'engagement de sa vie de
quelque sorte
voilà donc à 100 je monte sur la caisse
et la vie
ok voilà c'est juste pour rétablir les
sujets du fond je veux juste qu'on
finisse sur la question des lords et
migros peut-être qu'on pourra parler de
ce qui se passe à peu dans le 16e
arrondissement c'est amusant mais je
voudrais d'abord qu'on voit un sujet sur
que sont devenus les migrants qui ont
été accueillis dans les yvelines
donc là c'est un étage qui est dédié à
notre communauté afghane
vous avez une chambre sont échanges
individuels donc ce sont des petites
chambres
ils sont 73 à vivre ici au monastère des
orantes un pakistanais et deux afghans
et 59 tibétains des communautés
totalement différentes qui sont en
france pour la même raison
fuir la guerre dans leur pays d'origine
sonam et tibétaine et aujourd'hui elle
compte rester en france
si le tibet libéré je rentrerai mais
sinon je ne peux pas si je reviens là
bas je serai tué parce que là bas j'ai
pris part à des mouvements politiques
alors si je reviens je serai tué
tibétains et afghans cohabitent dans ce
centre d'hébergement soit comme
demandeurs d'asile ou réfugiés
statutaires
mais avec le même objectif rester en
france pour reconstruire leur vie
je dois rester ici je ne peux pas
rentrer dans mon pays ça n'est plus
possible je dois rester ici en france
j'étudie j'apprends le français j'ai
besoin d'apprendre c'est vraiment
important
apprendre le français l'une des
principales activités de ces réfugiés
tous les matins une association seront
au monastère pour dispenser des cours
l'objectif c'est de lui et les laisser
devenir autonome au plus vite
quoi qu'il puisse vraiment progresser
trouver du travail
s'intégrer plus facilement oui pour
monosphere le but ici bien sûr celui ci
n'est pas des gardés à bitam aeternam
c'est juste une période delà de leur vie
qui leur permet déjà de ceux de ce
reprendre d'essayer de de se poser pour
reconnaître un petit peu pour savoir ce
qu'ils veulent faire de leur avenir
nous avons donc des réfugiés statutaires
donc ça signifie dix ans a obtenu le
droit d'obtenir un titre de séjour de
dix ans en france est de travailler en
francs mais c'est l'état qui choisit
ensuite de les déplacer dans un autre
logement ou une autre ville
pour l'instant les réfugiés qui vivent
ici sont totalement libres il participe
aux tâches ménagères et à des activités
mais peuvent sortir quand bon leur
semble sous réserve de pointer tous les
trois jours
quand on voit qu'on a fait 60 bénévoles
se sont mis en association et qui
habitent tous dans la région et
particulièrement à bonal je pense que
c'est un bon reflet de ce que pense la
population sur sur ce monastère géré par
l'association habitat et humanisme ce
centre d'hébergement est avant tout un
lieu de repos et d'adaptation en plus
des 60 bénévoles pour les ateliers et
cours de français huit personnes
travaillent ici pour prodiguer un
accompagnement humain et administratifs
une sorte de tremplin social vers le
renouvellement
et alors de céder sur les migrants on
parlera peut-être des migrants une autre
fois parce qu'il nous reste à peine deux
minutes
je voudrais peut-être un mot sur ce jeu
vous avez sans doute vu ce qui s'était
passé dans le 16e arrondissement où
voilà on doit accueillir des logements
pour des sdf et où la population il
réunion la population une partie de la
population a refusé ces logements avec
des bots et choisissez les mots ce
dimanche est terrible et quelques images
et quelques commentaires des attitudes
de pâques chrétiennes pour le coup pour
la conversation d'avancé c'est étonnant
c'est dur très dur
c'est la peur de l'autre s'exprimer ils
ont le droit de s'exprimer comme tout le
monde mais de mesurer ils ont qu'à une
l'éducation ils ont quand même des
qualités et tous les prix les réserves
des langages minimum non mais surtout ce
que je comprends pas c'est que dans tous
les arrondissements paris il ya des
lieux d'accueil des sdf
il y en a pas dans le xvième donc
pourquoi pas dans le xvième enfin je
veux dire comme tout le monde pendant
comme dans toutes les villes
gérard larcher qui avait parlé l'autre
matin sur france inter sur rambouillet
où il a été accueilli avec une grande
pour lui je crois qu'il va y aura une
période un peu dissidente donc non les
baous outre et comme vous bien bu bien
évidemment mais la seule chose j'en
viens ce que j'ai tout à l'heure sur les
stigmatisations c'est à dire que quand
nous y aille à 3 abrutis du 9-3 qui vole
une voiture on n'a pas le droit et on ne
dit pas en tout cas je ne dis pas je dis
pas tous les habitants du 9-3 sont des
brûlures de voitures donc là j'aimerais
que quelques abrutis qui ai pris la
parole et non moins abruti qui l'ont
entendu un micro très content de faire
virer parce qu'elle est plus joli bond
au qu'on ne stigmatise pas non plus tout
le 16e n'est pas représentative
représenté par les quatre ou cinq
crétins qu'on a vu s'exprimer
c'est bien sûr sur cette parole digne de
monseigneur barbarin n'en a pas mois que
jean l'épauler
non non pas simplement là il s'agit de
sdf et payent pas dénigrer actuellement
chez les émigrés il ya les aigris
politique fait les formidables caddie
d'inquiéter pas il y aura pas de noir
une migros à tous à tous et amalgames et
sa grâce à disney ne laissons pas
manipuler
merci bas c'est sur cette parole que
nous conclurons merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui babec merci beaucoup samyn
caussens merci beaucoup florence père
cadets et merci beaucoup jean charles
lajoie ni